comment expliquez vous que le matin même
du jour où françois mitterrand quitte l
elysée pour passer les pouvoirs à
jacques chirac
comment ça se fait qu'il vous inviter à
se l'ultime petit déjeuner vous avez été
le dernier invité à l'elysée de françois
mitterrand et les dernières paroles
qu'il ait prononcé comme président de la
république à l'exception peut-être de
quelques mots qu'il a dit à son médecin
avant de passer la parole à chaque c'est
à moi que les adultes
je ne les explique pas je comme ça que
je raconte et je ne tire aucune
conclusion il faut dire d'ailleurs que
il y alla de deux mots qui ont presque
fait disparaître le livre ah oui alors
oui alors donc vous raconter ce petit
déjeuner vous parler de littérature vous
parlez de jaquettes y voit les choses
et puis à un moment vous dis alors gelé
le passage qui a soulevé des passions
j'évoque la sphère bousquet haut
fonctionnaire de vichy
beaucoup reprochent au président les
liens qui l'unissent à ce personnage qui
a joué un rôle important dans la
collaboration avec l'allemagne
hitlérienne françois mitterrand mais
coûte sans irritation apparente et ils
me regardent vous constatez la maudite
et l'influencé puissante et nocive du
lobby juif en france il y a un grand
silence
l'ombre de mon arrière-grand-mère passe
sur l'elysée alors qu'est ce que c'est
que l'ombre de votre arrière grand mère
qui passeront à l'homme voilà et un
grand verre c'est évidemment
ils cacherai pas que dans une secteur de
ma famille il y avait
les traces les juifs n'étaient pas
toujours traitées au moins en
conversation comme il fallait alors je
n'en veux simplement dire c'est qu'alors
donc les réactions je voudrais avec les
réactions alors certains des familiers
de france au bout d'un certains ont dit
oui oui il a certainement pendant ces
sept là il l'a dit autrefois et d'autres
familier 10 on dit doutent d'eux qu'ils
aient pu prononcer ces paroles ou alors
vous reproche s'il les a prononcés de
les avoir de les avoir mis noir sur
blanc dans le livre alors disons les
choses simplement
je crois que tout le monde presque tous
pratiquement tout le monde reconnaît que
ces paroles ont pu et probablement ont
dû être prononcées on ne met plus en
doute même quand on m'attaque avec une
violence inouïe que ces paroles est été
prononcé mais immédiatement après on me
dit il les a peut-être dit
mais il ne fallait pas le répétez pas
vous pas comme ça pas mal par mois pas
maintenant mais pourquoi je fais ce que
je veux
de ce que j'ai entendu je ne me livre à
aucun commentaire mais je répète
simplement ce qui m'a été dit et qui n'a
pas été dit sous le sceau du secret
qu'est ce que c'est saint-simon avec
louis xiv qui l'admirent qu'ils
détestent et qui n'est plus là qu'est ce
que fait chateaubriand avec napoléon
qu'il déteste qu'il admire et qui n'est
plus là alors les attaques c'est très
très bon ne croyait pas qu'elle me taper
sa tête et que je me prenne pour
chateaubriand et pour saint simon mais
tout simplement j'ai raconté ce que
j'avais entendu et je me suis livrée
pour ma part à aucun commentaire
les commentaires n'ont pas été mon fait
alors vous avez déclenché l'ire
de roger hanin qui vous a traité en
d'autres mots d'oiseaux il a traité de
crétin ridicule qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ces attaques
je crois que est ce que c'est la biche
ou courteline qui dit gagner plus grand
plaisir c'est d'être traité d'imbécile
par un idiot cellule abichou de
courteline question considérez vous que
l'expression le bij juif est une
expression antisémites alors je dois
vous dire que je ne suis pas entré
jusqu'à présent dans ce débat j'ai dit
ce que j'avais entendu et je ne suis pas
vous m'avez vu nulle part
vous n'avez aucune réponse lue par
daniel réponse nulle part pour ma part
si vous me demandez est-ce que vous
pensez que mitterrand était antisémite
japon va certainement par la négative
d'accord mais considérez vous que
l'expression le bij juif est une
expression antisémite par ni
nécessairement d'abord là dans cette
occasion là c'était évidemment le cri
d'un homme
exaspéré vous avez vous vous rappelez l
affaire bousquet la pression des médias
sur cet homme est certainement ça a été
le crie un homme qui en avait par dessus
le dos le musée juif c'est une formule
que je n'emploierai pas moi même mais il
ya évidemment des lobbys de céréaliers
des lobbys de pétroliers des lobbies de
toutes espèces
le l'expression le bij juifs vous savez
ce qui m'a frappé dans le tas de
françois mitterrand où je rapporte
simplement sans commentaire les paroles
qu'il a prononcées
je me suis dit que quand même falletti
clap l'est soit à vif
pour que le moindre mouvement râches de
tels crimes douleur mais lobby juif
donc ce n'est pas pour vous une
expression antisémites dans la bouche de
mitterrand non je ne le pense pas je
pense que c'était le cri d'un homme qui
était exaspéré par ce qu'il avait
entendu et par la pression à laquelle il
était saoul et diriez-vous que vous même
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans cette affaire
la cible d'un certain lobby juif aux non
vous savez ce que je suis je suis le
personnage tout à fait classique de la
tragédie antique qui apporte une
mauvaise nouvelle pour certains
et quand on ne peut pas détruire la
nouvelle on essaye de détruire le
message